today on the matt walsh show the senate
trial of donald trump continues and we
continue to be told about the deadly
riot in which five people were killed
but is it true
that five people were killed by the riot
how did that happen what are the details
we've been told very little
about that we'll take a look at what we
do know today also five headlines
including
joe biden's plan to raise the minimum
wage which which the congressional
budget office says
would wipe out thousands and thousands
of jobs and
one of the greatest videos in the
history of the internet goes viral
yesterday we'll play that plus
our daily cancellation where we will
discuss the insane
left-wing conspiracy theory surrounding
my favorite restaurant cracker barrel
all of that and much more today on the
matte wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know if you've had getting life
insurance on your to-do list for a long
time as a lot of people have
then uh don't wait any longer this is
the kind of thing you know
people wait and wait and wait until uh
could be too late policy genius can help
help you check off two big items with
ease compare life insurance rates and
save 50 or more in the process that
means more cash to put towards the
things that you care about whatever that
might be
there's absolutely no hassle for policy
genius their licensed experts work for
you
not the insurance companies so they can
offer unbiased advice
when you need it and here's how it works
first you head to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need compare quotes from
top insurers to find
your best price policy genius will
compare policies starting in as little
as one dollar
a day you might even be eligible for um
for skipping the in-person medical exam
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and red
tape
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they're going to
take care of everything
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across 1600
reviews on trustpilot and google
you can't get that kind of service
anywhere else policy genius just makes
it so easy for you to do this really
important thing and get life insurance
so if you're worried that march is just
around the corner and you've barely
gotten anything done
take a deep breath policy genius will
help you make the most of this short
month
in minutes you could say 50 or more by
comparing quotes and
feel good knowing that your loved ones
would be taken care of if anything would
happen to you
so go to policygenius.com to get started
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
we've been told time and time again that
the ride in dc on january 6th was
deadly or fatal or lethal as it has been
variously described by the media uh this
point is being hammered with extra
enthusiasm during the senate impeachment
trial of donald trump this week and it's
a point that the media has embedded into
the public consciousness over the course
of the last month
five deaths you know that's that's the
number we've been given in fact
all in all a total of seven deaths have
been tied to the riot
uh four citizens and three police
officers and when i say these right
these deaths have been tied to the riot
i mean that the connection has been made
by the media and by the the political
class by democrats
not really by any official source see
the odd thing is that these deaths are
only discussed in the most
general and vague terms if you haven't
noticed
we're told that people died and were
given the approximate
context of their deaths but very little
is said about
how it happened but the how seems rather
important doesn't it
don't you wonder that when you hear five
people died and riot isn't your first
question
how the heck did that happen
it's important for the families who have
a right to know exactly how and why
their loved ones perished and it's
important to the american
public which has a right to know the
full truth about an event that's been
used to justify the indefinite
militarization of our capital
the impeachment of a former president i
think we all have a right to know what
happened
it's important most of all because the
truth simply matters
it matters for its own sake putting
everything else aside
if we're gonna be told so often and in
such dramatic terms that the riot
claimed the lives of five people or even
seven people
then we should be told how exactly that
occurred and if the people making the
claim
don't themselves know how it occurred
then they shouldn't be making the claim
at all
if they do know and they aren't telling
us then that opens up a whole new realm
of problems so based on the available
information let's take a closer look
at these deaths and the circumstances
surrounding them
out of seven deaths in some way tied
back to the riot
and out of the three police officer
deaths we know that two
were tragic suicides in the days and
weeks following the chaos acting
metropolitan police chief robert conti
said that uh that officers jeffrey smith
and howard
liebengood took their own lives in the
aftermath
of that battle now does that mean that
the trauma of the event pushed them over
the edge
did they leave notes or make statements
indicating that the riot itself had
caused that kind of psychological damage
or did they have other things going on
internally or in their personal lives
that led to this tragic conclusion is
there any
evidence at all that the events of
january 6
played any role in their suicides
if anybody if anybody knows the answers
to those questions they aren't telling
us
all that we can say for sure is that two
men who were serving in the line of duty
when a riot broke out later went on to
take their own lives
anybody who connects these two facts is
making an assumption
and i would say a rather cynical and
inappropriate and
actually outrageous assumption
as for the civilian deaths tied to the
riot we know
at least their names here are their
names
benjamin phillips ashley babbitt
roseanne boyland and kevin greeson
it was reported by chief conte himself
immediately after the riot that three of
the victims phillips boylan and greeson
died from quote separate medical
emergencies kevin greeson's family later
confirmed that he had high blood
pressure and died of a heart attack
quote in the midst of the excitement
even fewer details have been given about
benjen philip benjamin phillips's death
but we do know that he suffered a stroke
at some at some point on january 6th and
then later
uh that was taken to a hospital and died
in the hospital for roseanne boylan the
story is even murkier it was initially
reported by the media that boyland was
trampled to death
now this would certainly qualify
unquestionably as a death caused by the
riot
yet a more in-depth examination of her
death in the new york times
shows that she collapsed while amid a
flood of people near the capitol
building
others in the crowd tried to revive her
gave her cpr but she eventually died
anyway the chief medical examiner of
washington dc has it january 21st anyway
said that her cause of death is pending
was she indeed trampled to death did or
did she suffer some other
medical emergency like the two other
fatalities i just mentioned
did she have trouble breathing because
of the crush of people
that you have any kind of pre-existing
condition we're left only to speculate
ashley babbitt is the clearest case of
all case of all she was certainly killed
by violence during the riot no question
about that
but she was killed by a police officer
not a rioter
she was killed while trying to climb
through a broken door inside the capitol
building
babbitt was unarmed and she was shot
through the neck and she died
quickly that leaves officer brian
sicknick
now in many ways the circumstances
surrounding his death are the murkiest
of all
immediately following the riot the
capitol police issued a statement saying
that an officer had quote passed away
due to the injury sustained while on
duty
and we were told that he quote returned
to his division office and collapsed and
then he was taken to a hospital where he
died
the times and others reported that the
officer soon identified as brian
sicknick was bludgeoned with a with a
fire extinguisher by someone or multiple
people in the crowd
and this is the story that stuck that he
was bludgeoned to death as prominent
human rights lawyer kasim rasheed put it
on january 8th
he said sickness quote was beat to death
by a fire extinguisher to his skull
by right-wing terrorists and that was
the narrative
that's been the narrative all along
that's what most people think happened
the problem with the narrative is that
it doesn't appear to be true
now little has been officially revealed
about siknik's cause of death
common theme here emerging and the
autopsy results for whatever reason have
not been made available to the public
but in a report
that didn't receive much attention or
emphasis last week cnn reveals this and
i'm going to quote from their article
it's kind of long so just bear with me
but all this information is important
and i want to give it to you exactly how
they put it
so they say quote investigators are
struggling to build a federal murder
case regarding fallen u.s capitol police
officer brian siknik vexed by a lack of
evidence that could prove someone caused
his death as he defended the capital
during last month's insurrection
authorities have reviewed video and
photographs that show signic engaging
with rioters amid the siege
but have yet to identify a moment in
which he suffered his fatal injuries
law enforcement officials familiar with
the matter uh this is what
this is what law enforcement officials
familiar with matter said
continuing to date little information
has been shared publicly about the
circumstances of the death of the
13-year veteran of the police force
including any findings from an autopsy
that was conducted by dc's medical
examiner
findings from a medical examiner's
review have not yet been released and
authorities have not made any
announcements about the ongoing process
according to one law enforcement
official medical examiners did not find
signs that the officer sustained any
blunt force trauma
so investigators believe that early
reports that he was fatally struck by a
fire extinguisher are not true
one possibility being considered by
investigators is that siknik became ill
after interacting with a chemical
irritant like pepper spray or bear spray
that was deployed in the crowd
but investigators reviewing video of the
officer's time around the capitol
haven't been able to confirm
that in the tape which has been
recovered so far
the case could also be complicated if
siknik had a pre-existing medical
condition
it could not be learned if he did all
right
what this all means is that sicknick's
death well obviously tragic no matter
what caused it
was not necessarily the result of any
direct action taken by anyone in the
crowd there is to date according to
these reports
no evidence at all that sicknick was
murdered
there is no evidence at least none
provided to the public that his death
was caused
by the riot even indirectly
all we actually know all we've been told
is that officer signing was at the riot
and then he died later that is the
full extent of the information
officially given to the public
that's it this officer was there and he
died later
now i'm not joking with you when i tell
you that is literally all we've been
told
officially overall based on the
available evidence we can say
conclusively
that one person not five
one was directly killed by violence in
the riot
that's what we can say conclusively
one person directly killed by violence
in the riot
and that's the person who was killed by
a capital police officer
as she was unarmed
we could say with relative certainty
that two others died of medical
emergencies stemming from underlying
health concerns
so that leaves two sicknick and boyland
whose deaths are still a relative
mystery
again a mystery to us in the public
now presumably the autopsy results could
lend
quite a bit of clarity but those results
are being withheld i'm no doctor i admit
but i i would guess
that anyone can correct me if i'm wrong
but i would guess that an autopsy a
medical examination could rather
conclusively determine whether a person
was or was not
trampled to death in one case or beat to
death in the other
it would seem to me that that's the kind
of thing
that through doing a medical examination
an autopsy
you'd be able to tell
yet if those determinations were made
we're being kept in the dark
what this means is that anyone who
connects five deaths to the riot
is spreading misinformation they're
making these connections based on
assumption
rumor and speculation now i don't want
to engage in my own speculation
so i'm not going to speculate about
why we are not being told the autopsy
results
of officer brian sicknick
you know if we are ever told it seems
that it is going to be
after the senate trial of donald trump
i'm not going to speculate about whether
those two things are connected
but at a certain point
common sense has to take over on that
end anyway
there's a lot we still don't know and
for anyone who says
well we shouldn't wait how dare you even
talk about this
people died that's all that matters it's
a tragedy
yeah it is a tragedy
but the fact that people died is not the
only thing that matters
how they died also matters
and we deserve to know the truth
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
one of the one of the best gifts that
you can give yourself is the gift of
knowledge
of learning because the process of
learning is something whatever your
education level is
um whatever your sort of official
education level is this is something we
all have to continue to do is learn and
grow
and uh and become better more you know
deeper more interesting people in
process
and that's why you should check out
great courses i've been a big great
courses
fan for a long time for years now and
with their latest the great courses plus
you have unlimited access to thousands
of videos and audio lectures on hundreds
of fascinating topics you can learn a
new language you can discover
what einstein got wrong you can even
gain valuable insights into your own
public persona
so many different subjects and so if
you're like me and you're kind of like
you got a million different subjects
that you're interested in it's hard to
figure out which one you want to focus
on first um well they've got
just go through just go through the
catalog and you get unlimited access you
can listen to
and watch as much as you want the
courses are taught by the best
professors and top experts in their
fields
and the material is all extensively
vetted and researched it's high quality
content reliable fact-based information
that you can trust
so this is not going to be just
something that you read on the internet
you don't know if it's true or not we're
not talking about learning on wikipedia
here this is a great courses plus
and plus with the great courses plus app
you're free to watch listen and learn on
any device at any time
no matter where you are in the world
like i said i've been using great
courses for a long time one of the most
recent courses ever
a couple of recent courses on biblical
history what i find is that
interesting subject to sit down and read
a book on biblical history can sometimes
be a little bit dry hard to get into
but with the um with the lecturers
professors they have
um you know on on the subject of
biblical history
or anything else they're very
interesting they get you absorbed into
it and it's
easy and fun to learn so i'm glad i
found a more productive way to spend my
time and i want you to try the great
courses plus two get started with a free
month of unlimited access
just visit my special url
thegreatcoursesplus.com
walsh that's a whole month to learn
anything you want for free
so sign up now remember
thegreatcoursesplus.com
walsh all right um
you know i don't mean to to air my
marital dirty laundry or anything like
that
but um i got you know a little bit of
tense moment with my
my wife last night because uh i
told her my plan
and i had i had the scissors in my hand
and i said my plan
is to trim my beard down to make it
pointy
like like a like a wizard you know like
a wizard sort of point and i really i
i've been giving this a lot of thought
and i thought pointy beard is the way to
go
she was very
unaccepting of that idea and this is one
thing you know you realize
uh as a as a married man and i get a lot
of beard related questions and this is
one thing i'll just tell you before we
move on here
um one one tip here is that when you're
you think as a as a man when you grow a
beard it's your beard right
but what you realize is that your beard
is not your own and your wife is gonna
have a lot of opinions
about what you can and can't do with
your beard i've had so many
beard-related plans that have been shot
down by my wife
you know at different times goatee
handlebar mustache
all these things and uh she
she feels entitled with this i think
women feel entitled to stop you
my body my choice right those are my
words to her exactly and she was not uh
she was not convinced
all right now speaking of the senate
impeachment trial from from the daily
wire it says former president donald
trump is reportedly furious
with the way this impeachment defense
team performed on day one of the senate
trial
um two sources this from fox news
correspondent kevin cork
two sources of fact who spent time with
the former president today described him
as quote being
furious and beyond angry with his
impeachment defense team
he was especially upset with attorney
bruce castro
um in his rambling opening argument
the the former president spending the
day watching the trial from inside his
private quarters at mar-a-lago
no golf with the very same plan for
tomorrow and so he's very upset now we
have i think we have some of the
um this is bruce castor by the way not
castro
so bruce cassary he's the one of trump's
defense attorneys
and his his performance yesterday anyway
was
roundly panned by everyone this is
bipartisan
right left and center and here's a
little bit i guess you could decide how
compelling you think this is but here's
a little bit of what bruce castor said
on the floor of the senate yesterday
this trial is not about
trading liberty for security
it's about trading it's about suggesting
that it is a good idea that we give up
those liberties that we have so
long fought for uh
what and that was that was
much of what he had to say was along
those
lines and when i say along those lines i
mean indecipherable
hard to understand what he was even
trying to say
i mean it appears that trump's defense
team went in to this trial
with no plan they had there's no defense
strategy at all it's not just that like
they had a bad defense strategy
they they had no strategy they just
thought they just woke up
it seemed like they woke up that morning
and said like me
in in high school so often they woke up
that morning and they said oh crap we
have
is that senate is that senate trial is
that today
and so in the car on the way over
they're just frantically
putting together opening statement and
everything
um you know i know that there's people
in the audience who don't want to hear
this
even now after all this time you know
that there are some people who who
simply have
no tolerance for any criticism of donald
trump whatsoever but i
i will say that for my money perhaps the
the the most untrue thing that donald
trump ever said in his whole life
most false thing that he ever said was
when he said uh that he hires the best
people
and we have seen time and time again
that he does not hire the best people
in fact perhaps his greatest weakness is
in personnel
in the people that he hires just a
parade
of incompetent clowns through his
administration and after
oftentimes hiring the worst people to
providing the worst people possible
you tell me they're no lawyers you're a
former president you're a billionaire
that's the best you can find and i know
there are a lot of lawyers who don't
want to touch it with a 10-foot poll but
really you couldn't find anybody with
all your money
hard to believe okay from nbc news it
says raising the federal minimum wage to
15
an hour proposed a proposal supported by
president joe biden
would result in the loss of 1.4 million
jobs
but would bring nearly 1 million people
out of poverty over the next four years
the study conducted by the non-partisan
congressional budget office
was also found that increasing the
minimum wage would raise the cumulative
budget deficit from 2021 to 2023 by 54
billion dollars
and would drive inflation resulting in
higher prices for goods and services
the cbo evaluated proposal that would
gradually increase the minimum wage
reaching
uh 15 an hour by 2025. okay so
15 in our minimum wage the stuff about
the deficit
increasing by 54 billion dollars that's
the kind of thing that
should disturb us we we should care um
that's a that's an argument that should
be effective
is pointing out the increase in deficit
but what we've discovered is that really
nobody
cares about the deficit nobody cares
about spending
um it's we sort of this is just the
truth
both sides of the aisle we take turns
pretending to care when the other
when the other side's person is in
office i mean how many conservatives
over the last four years of trump
said a damn thing about it's too much
spending deficit
all that was out the window was very
little was was said about that
um and that's just the way it goes and
of course but on the left they
they're people that sort of became all
the sudden budget hawks under trump and
now it goes the other way so this is the
way it goes
um that is not going to be it should
probably be an effective
line of argument against any plan is by
saying how it'll increase the deficit
but
um it's not now the part about
losing a million jobs there you go i
mean that that's something people do
care about
should care about and do and in fact
um speaking of related news i think this
is from
biz journals it says uh kroger is about
to test its first store that offers only
self-service checkout lanes
using enhanced capabilities downtown
cincinnati-based kroger the nation's
largest operator of traditional
supermarkets plans to launch the pilot
test of the all
self-checkout store in dallas on
february
17th it's converting one of its smaller
stores um
on cedar springs road for the for the
pilot now this is not
they're not directly making a connection
here but i think we can see the
connection if you
if you try to force these companies to
pay people 15 an hour to do labor that
just
isn't worth that
especially when it's labor that can be
replaced
with machines then that's what's going
to happen i don't like it
i think personally i would much rather
have the people there having you know
in even as an antisocial person myself
i will use the self checkout lane just
on antisocial grounds
so i guess i'm part of the problem as
far as that goes if you give me that
option then i'll take it
but i recognize that in in reality it
probably would be best if i didn't have
that option
it'd probably be best if there are
actual people doing those jobs
so that is better um
but you force these companies to pay 15
an hour and this is what's gonna happen
as i've said many times the the minimum
wage
should be zero you know that that's
where you start that that's
that's the minimum or maybe a penny like
that's that's the actual minimum of what
of what labor could possibly be worth
and you go up from there and one thing
that gets lost in this discussion
is um is
not only wiping out jobs but if you're
forcing
the employer to pay everyone 15 an hour
effectively giving a raise maybe to some
people who have not
actually earned that and aren't aren't
doing a job that's worth 15
an hour then there could be a lot of
other employees at that store
who could be worth 20 or 25 an hour very
worthy of of promotion and raises and
now won't get it
because the government is forcing the
employer to give a raise even the people
who haven't earned it
that to me is also a problem
we've we've all had this experience
right when you go to a fast food place
you go
you're interacting with customer service
we've we've all
gone into a grocery store to a fast food
place and we've interacted with customer
service representative
who basically just when you look at them
it's like they're trying to visibly
murder you you can you can see visible
hatred in their eyes
it's not even just bad customer service
it's it's it's hateful because
they hate you for being there so we've
all experienced that
but then we also experienced customer
service people someone working in a
register working at a test
who's just wonderful delightful they put
a smile on your face
they're absolutely on top of it the idea
that they should be paid exactly the
same
or that person who hates you just for
being there is automatically worth
15 bucks an hour all they do is show up
make put in absolutely zero effort
whatsoever and they're automatically
worth 15
an hour no i would rather
free up these companies to pay someone
like that like five bucks an hour
i mean you're putting in zero effort
zero
the only effort is just to walk in the
door so pay them five and then
that really awesome customer service
representative who's really on top of it
and makes you feel
good and you know they're just really
really good pay them 30 bucks an hour
that to me seems the most just the most
fair all right number three pete
butterjudge for some reason
is um secretary of transportation and he
wants to bring equity to the roadways
his plan for for social justice and
equity he wants to bring it to the
roadways where it does not belong
and uh here he is explaining his plan
what's the biggest way
that transportation has been permanently
changed by the pandemic
it's too soon to know for sure but i
think it's safe to say that our
old patterns of life uh the nine to five
monday through friday commuting patterns
are not going to be exactly the same
yeah and so how might that change what
your staff does uh you know we think
trains planes and automobiles but uh
what about bike scooters wheelchairs for
that matter those are things you plan to
pay more attention to absolutely yeah
look roads aren't only for vehicles
we got to make sure that pedestrians and
individuals and bicyclists and
businesses can all
co-exist on the same roadway yeah what
about what about scooters and bikes
what about pogo sticks what about
unicycles
you know what about big wheel uh bikes
what about those yeah we'll put them all
in the roadways
wheelchairs on the roadway now if you
if if what you mean is a wheelchair
crossing the street in the crosswalk
then sure yeah
okay but if you're talking about what uh
when you say
share the road it makes it sound like
you're talking about people in
motorized wheelchairs actually just
driving down the street
which i have seen in fact i've seen it
in nashville more than once
it's extremely dangerous for the person
in that wheelchair that should not be
encouraged
now i'm not gonna go to my whole rant
again i did a whole daily cancellation
on it weeks ago
and i think it's one of the most
important segments i've ever done on the
show
uh about about cyclists specifically on
the roadway
now my stance is very clear the the road
modern roads modern paved roads
are are actually built for vehicles and
vehicles are what belong on those roads
not people on bikes holding up traffic
getting themselves and other people
killed
certainly not wheelchairs not not even
see we have we have something called
a sidewalk okay and i think sidewalks
are great inventions
and um it sounds like maybe that's what
footage is reaching for here he's
thinking about inventing sidewalks
again sidewalks are fantastic yeah put
all
all the all the things he just mentioned
scooters bikes wheelchairs pedestrians
put them all on sidewalks
cars go on the road i think that's a
great system it really has worked pretty
well hasn't it
i don't i don't think we need to
reinvent the wheel here so to speak
cars on the road everyone else on the
sidewalk great
no problem you want to build more
sidewalks go ahead and do that
um number four mask shaming is a
favorite pastime of
of some people in america as we've
noticed and those are
people who are you know cowards and
proud of it
and uh here's the latest incident here's
a here's a man
i think is one of the worst we've seen
because it's a man harassing and filming
a woman
and her elderly mother at a store for
not wearing a mask and here's how that
went
say cheese you're in costco not wearing
your mask refusing to wear your mask
[Music]
and here's her mother
can you call your manager can you call
her
your manager
we've seen this play out many times
the guy sees these two women one of whom
again is an elderly woman you know
speaking of you know she's in a
motorized
scooter speaking of which and you look
at her there in that
in that video that see that that is a
a vehicle that does not belong in the
roadway and it's not in this case that's
very good
that's one that belongs in a store in
the sidewalk um here's an elderly woman
and her you know daughter who's older as
well
and he's afraid because she's not
wearing a mask
so his response is to put her on film go
right up in her face and get her on
get her on camera pull out his phone and
start tattletailing
start snitching calling for a manager
once again if you're that afraid that
this person is going to spread a disease
then maybe just keep on walking just
keep moving your ass
and go to a different part of the store
if i will never understand this if i was
afraid that someone had a deadly disease
and they were going to spread it to me
the last thing i would do is take out my
camera to document it and get right up
in their face
say hey you're endangering people's
lives right up in their face no i
wouldn't do that
never have cowards been so eager to
advertise their own cowardice
he this guy is more afraid
than that elderly woman the elderly
woman you know she's
she's in the most vulnerable category
and she's not that concerned he's more
afraid than she is and he's
he's happy to advertise that to the
whole world
pathetic all right um here's something
that's not so pathetic i have to play
this for you because honestly i believe
it's one of the internet's greatest
gifts to mankind
you've probably already seen it if you
spend any time on the internet then you
probably couldn't
escape yesterday without seeing this um
but we're gonna play it again anyway and
uh
and because i think it's in the running
for maybe the funniest internet video of
all time
and unfortunately if you're listening to
the audio podcast um
and you haven't seen this video you're
not gonna be able to fully appreciate it
you you have to see the visual so i
apologize for that but you can always
come to youtube and check out this
segment at least
because you need you need to see this
you need to see to appreciate all of the
the subtlety of the humor you have to
actually see it but um
here we have a hearing with
a a few lawyers and a judge i don't know
what the hearing was about
doesn't matter and apparently some of
the back story here is that one of the
lawyers in this hearing with the judge
is the zoom you know that we do
everything on zoom now so it's a zoom
hearing
and he was using his secretary's
computer and the secretary has a young
daughter
who had previously been on zoom and was
using a certain filter
and this filter had not been taken off
and so then this is what happened i
believe you have a
filter turned on in the video settings
you might want to uh uh
we're trying to we're can you hear me
judge
i can hear you i think it's a filter
it is and i don't know how to remove it
i've got my assistant here she's trying
to but
uh i'm prepared to go forward with it
that's i'm here live that's not i'm not
a cat
i can i can see that i'm not i'm here
live i'm not a cat everything
what this is why i say you have to see
it okay because
the the facial expressions of the cat
are what really sell this there's one
moment in particular
when he first realizes that he's a cat
and he kind of looks down and he's got
this shocked
a confused expression the cat has a
shock confused expression
the cat just just nails the feeling i i
didn't know that the filters were this
advanced because there's this there's
this oh crap i'm a cat
moment and and look i've never seen that
look especially on a cat
it's like his cat's having an
existential crisis
and that in particular when he lets out
this kind of like grown
um that's the part that really sells and
then the whole thing
where he has to clarify that he's not a
cat which i have to say as many people
on the internet said yesterday
you know uh that's what a cat would say
if if you have if you find yourself in a
situation where you have to actually say
out loud i'm not a cat
that might that means you might actually
be a cat
so who knows we don't know what actually
happened there's a lot we don't know in
this situation too but um
that's great now um the other
hilarious uh video
that that has graced the internet this
week which we played yesterday was the
um
gorilla glue girl as she has come to be
known
uh that is tessica brown you remember
she's the the woman
who sprayed industrial glue in her hair
because she ran out of hairspray and so
she just figured well you know
this is a an adhesive kind of substance
might as well just put it in my hair and
so she did that
and um and then her hair ended up just
being
crusted into place for a whole month as
as you might expect
ended up going to the er they couldn't
do anything about it now she's thinking
about filing a lawsuit against gorilla
glue
and like i told you yesterday and i i
hate to be the bearer of bad news
she will well if she doesn't win the
lawsuit it will probably
they'll probably settle with her and
she's going to make a lot of money she
shouldn't
but that's the way things go now because
all she's gonna need to prove
is that uh there was there was nothing
on the bottle specifically clarifying
not to use it in your in your hair and
there wasn't
all the bottle said was don't spray it
on your skin and your eyes are on your
clothes didn't say anything about hair
you would think you would need to say
that but um
but apparently you do now this woman
tessica brown
has actually gotten a lot of sympathy
online there's been a lot of sympathy
for this woman
and she has a gofundme of course
and that gofundme is up to seventeen
thousand almost eighteen thousand
we're talking eighteen thousand dollars
people are donating to a woman because
she put glue in her
hair and you read some of these comments
like here's some of the comments on the
gofundme page for the gorilla glue
girl um so it says believe in god you're
in my prayers and i pray
the doctors can clear this all for you
with complete healing now and in the
future
be encouraged to know that all things
are possible with god
all things are possible with god yeah he
can get the glue out of your hair all
things are possible
that's true the other god could get the
glue out of your hair
i kind of think god's going to make you
but this is one where god's going to say
you know
you're on your own on this one um and
someone else says praying that it all
turns out well um someone else says
i i pray that she'll be okay someone
else says i know the road ahead is not
going to be easy but hang in there and
just ignore the negativity i hope you
find healing on the inside as well as on
the outside
um and there was another comment that i
really
liked oh we all make mistakes you're
still
smart beautiful strong and courageous i
i
appreciate i i guess i have to
appreciate
how generous these people are being but
first of all yeah we all make mistakes
we don't all make that mistake in fact
nobody in history as far as we know has
ever made that mistake but her she's
totally alone
she is she is in a in an arena all by
herself
here she's in a league of her own and
and
not in a good way are you really praying
are the people went home last night and
they got on their knees and they prayed
for the woman who had glue in her hair
now again all things are possible with
god um god
is omnipotent and omniscient he can he
can hear all prayers he can respond to
all prayers so you know
you can't like overtax god but at the
same time
so many things to pray about in the
world and you made time to pray about
the woman with glue in her hair
and to give her money what would really
make me angry is i'm not even going to
look
you look at her 18 000 on gofundme for
glue in her hair
compare that to like people with cancer
who have gothamies or people people
whose kids have cancer
i bet you're gonna find a lot of
gofundmes for
for cancer stricken children that have
not raised 18
000 on gofundme so let's get our uh
priorities straight would be my
suggestion okay now moving on to the
newest uh
segment and the greatest which we call
reading the youtube comments where i in
fact read the youtube comments here are
a few comments left on the show
yesterday
k.s hudders says matt give us a list of
a few people who
who you think could actually be
president in 2024
i personally wish ron paul would run
again but he's way too old now
yeah i would say he's what is he like 97
now i'd say he's probably too old
um ron desantis is the guy that i've
been mentioning uh and
and i i i think others are gonna i think
there are other potential
candidates that that maybe you could
mention right now i think that four
years is a long time and other
people hopefully it's enough time to
find other candidates and draft them and
find find talented people
um you know the the the
the mainstream republican party on the
national level if you look at
republicans in congress
there may be a lot of incompetent clowns
there
but on the right generally plenty of
very
talented incompetent people so
if i had to cast a vote right now for
2024 it would be
for ron desantis but i think there are
many other um
potential candidates as well the only
thing is if trump runs again
in 2024 as a 78 year old man
and we have to do all this all over
again then i i really don't think he's
going to win
but he he i don't think he'd win the
general he would win the primary for
sure and he would suck up all the oxygen
and all of this up-and-coming talent
these really talented guys like like ron
desantis would be
would suffocate from the lack of oxygen
um which is why i really think we need
to start moving forward and thinking
about who
you know who's going to be the next
generation
all right um
matthew says matt i love your new
segment appropriately named reading the
youtube comments but i think it'd be
better if you read comments from the
daily wire website
it would add a layer of exclusivity if
you read comments from your live stream
chat
or the comments on your articles on the
dw website this way only those who are
behind the paywall can participate and
would entice the youtube freeloaders to
get a membership
matthew how about you try to stop trying
to micromanage me stop telling me what
to do how about that
you're banned from listening to the show
done get out
uh but thanks for the comment anyway um
diana vegas says i just want to thank
matt for being one of the main voices to
steer me away from the left last year i
may not agree with everything he says
but his dry sarcastic demeanor and logic
are what the world needs right now
well thank you diana and this really and
i mean that sincerely
you know being able to because some
i can say whatever i want present
whatever arguments i want
but but you have to be willing to think
critically
to listen to the arguments think
critically about them
um you have to be willing to adjust your
entire world view
you have to be willing to consider the
possibility that you've been wrong about
a lot of things for a long time
and most people in this country today
are simply not willing to do that
it takes a lot of intellectual courage
so i'll give you a credit for that
um and cowafungus really i'm just
reading this because i love the username
kawafunga says in case you didn't notice
it's time for secession
there simply aren't any other choices
now i've i've said many times i think
the idea of a national divorce
is um is good i would be i would be in
favor of a of a
i i i i i think it's i can't think of
another solution
anyway um i don't see us all coming
together and unifying
magically as much as it'd be nice if we
would i don't see that actually
happening
but i also haven't seen a plan for
secession that seems feasible
so you draw that up and uh let me know
and we could talk
there are a few things worse in life
than hearing that sound of the alarm
clock going off
um when you feel like you just fell
asleep 30 minutes ago
because you're tossing and turning all
night you're not comfortable you're not
getting any sleep and then the alarm
goes off
and you got to start the day and there's
no there's no pushing it back you can
snooze a few times if you're me you
snooze 10 times
until your wife kicks you in the face
and makes you get out of bed um
but nothing worse than that on the other
side nothing better than
waking up after in feeling actually
rested and if you if you it's been a
while since you felt really rested then
you might want to look into helix sleep
helix sleep has a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences
to the perfect mattress for you if you
like a mattress that's really soft or
firm
you sleep on your side or your back your
stomach or your sleep really hot
uh with with helix there's a specific
mattress for each and everybody's unique
taste
you don't need to take their word for it
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress of 2019 and 2020 by gq
and wired magazine
just go to helixsleep.com walsh take
their two-minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
we have a helix sleep mattress and i can
attest it really is the best sleep of
your life
and um the only downside is that once
you've slept on a helix
mattress you're not gonna wanna sleep on
any other mattress it's like make it
difficult sometimes when you're
traveling but um it's always great when
you get back to that bed so right now
helix is offering up to 200
off and free pillows with all mattress
orders for our listeners at helix sleep
dot com slash wall studs helix sleep dot
com slash walls for up to 200
off your mattress order one other thing
here's possibly the best news you're
going to hear all day right now
using promo code walsh you'll get 10 off
any daily wire membership plan
let me tell you if you're not a member
you are missing all the best stuff what
makes a membership so great
well members get our articles ad free
access to all of our live broadcasts
show library two two full hours of ben
shapiro show at our always growing
catalog of content you know about all
the great stuff we've got coming up this
year
well if you want access to that now's
the time plus with our all access you'll
get
you'll receive two of the greatest of
all beverage vessels the leftist tiers
tumbler
all of that plus 10 off when using promo
code walsh
so go over to thedailywire.com and
become a member
today
become a member today the dailywire.com
now let's get to our daily cancellation
you know there are only a few corporate
chains whose honor and dignity i will
defend to my dying breath
bass bass pro shops is one arby's is
another and rounding out the trio
is that realm of culinary delight known
as cracker barrel um i i maintain that
you simply will not find
a better meatloaf dish with three sides
for under 12 anywhere in the world
i dare you to try maybe it's maybe a low
bar but still
also across the entire american
southeast there are like 46 cracker
barrels per square mile
it's become such a part of the landscape
that you either develop an affection for
it or you become
deeply depressed and i have chosen
affection in this case and so
it may be partly because of this deep
affection that i take personally the
recent efforts by some on the left to
turn cracker barrel
racist this is one of the weirder trends
among progressive race hustlers
they notice a lot of white people
congregating in buildings
in these cracker barrel buildings
disappearing inside for hours at a time
re-emerging with a fatter stomach and
carrying a scented candle and a bag of
hard candy from the gift shop
and they figure that something sinister
must be happening inside
something racist and that's why a few
months ago cracker barrel you may
remember made headlines because there
was a
quote noose hanging from the ceiling in
one of their restaurants and this
sparked outrage until it was discovered
that the noose was actually not a noose
but the cord of an antique soldering
iron
but no worries said the media you know
they simply changed their headlines and
reported that a quote here's cnn's
phrasing a quote
noose-like cord was found in a cracker
barrel
yes if you can't get away with calling
it a noose just call it
noose like and the great thing is that
literally
any rope string or chord can be called
noose like
now if you thought that would be the
most desperate attempt to racistify
cracker barrel um you were wrong
yesterday the chain was trending again
this time due to a meme posted by some
random twitter account
which makes the following claim this is
the claim
cracker was a slang term for whip that's
why blacks called whites crackers
from the crack of the whip a cracker
barrel is a barrel that held the whips
for sale at the country store
you see the whip going from the r to the
k in the logo
racism in your face now this claim that
cracker barrel was named after
barrels of whips sold at the country
store for plantation owners to use on
their slaves
this claim was amplified and repeated
and immediately unquestionably accepted
by thousands of people
sophia nelson who's a self-described
self-described award-winning journalist
retweeted uh this claim with the caption
heavyside
i really like cracker barrel but now
that i see this and i get it
i sadly no longer can eat there and she
passed this along
to her 74 000 followers this is what
award-winning journalists do now
they see a meme accept it absolutely
and on face value and then promptly
spread it as a fact to the public
the backlash was so intense that uh
eventually cracker barrel actually had
to issue a statement
addressing it and denying
the racist origins of their name now
an intelligent person uh of which there
are there is a dwindling supply in this
country
upon hearing this claim about barrels of
whips might immediately suspect that
something isn't right first of all
why would you sell whips in a barrel of
all things
wouldn't they get tangled isn't that the
most
impractical way to sell whips wait you
could go to lowe's or home depot and
find all kinds of ropes and cords for
sale
news like items cnn would say uh and
and what you'll find is that they're all
hanging or or placed neatly on shelves
if you walk into a lowe's and say excuse
me can you point me to your
barrel of ropes they're going to look at
you like you're insane
the other problem with the claim is that
it's completely made up
maybe that's the main problem with it is
that it's just completely totally
made up this is a thing that somebody on
the internet simply invented out of
whole cloth and posted
there is zero truth to it as it turns
out and shockingly even snopes
did a fact check on this um the term
cracker barrel comes from
literal barrels of crackers that used to
be sold at country stores
now a barrel of crackers seems itself
sort of impractical and unsanitary
um but you know this was a different
time people back in those days thought
nothing of sticking their hand into a
huge barrel
and pulling out a wad of crackers
and then they buy the handful of
crackers for a nickel or whatever it was
and
that's where the name comes from the
cracker barrel origin story that went
viral yesterday was
essentially a conspiracy theory and this
is what we have to understand
this is a conspiracy theory and this is
how left-wing conspiracy theories often
work
we know about the conspiracy theories on
the right q anon sandy hook trutherism
and so on
we hear plenty about those but the left
has its own
um just just they just look a little
different and are built on different
background assumptions
the most basic background assumption for
the left-wing conspiracy theory is that
everything is racist
every institution is racist and racism
that is bigotry by white people against
non-white people specifically
is embedded into everything in our
culture see that's conspiracy theories
are all about
finding patterns where they don't exist
or finding patterns where they do exist
and then inventing extravagant and
fantastical explanations for those
patterns
this happens on both sides of the aisle
it is very far from an exclusively
right-wing phenomenon
claiming that the cracker barrel logo is
a racist dog whistle from a store with
mysterious new
nooses hanging in its gift shop is a
conspiracy theory every bit as
ridiculous and invented as the claim
that a pizza shop in dc
is the staging ground for a child sex
trafficking ring
the only difference again is the
background assumption that goes into it
and so cracker barrel is not cancelled
it will never be canceled on my watch
as long as it keeps serving that
delicious meatloaf but
the conspiracy theorists smearing its
good name are
absolutely canceled
that's gonna do it for us today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily dailywire2021 today on
the ben shapiro show we review day
one of the democrats impeachment trial
against president trump plus
the biden administration they continue
to push radical policy right under
everybody's nose that's today on the ben
shapiro show give it a listen